one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday a very
special Tuesday because yagar Elisa back
in studio yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
back in studio so exciting to be with my
swirly back in each other's arms but
we've been doing like so good and funny
remote no the way I've never been more
sure of our talents like I feel
reinvigorated
the remote has been just now I'm like
worried did we is the remote speechless
it's a remote magic usurping the studio
man no no never the thing is the magic
lies within it's so true no matter who
you uh where you're from what you did as
long as you're toasty like you and I are
the magic no matter the format like I
feel very confident in that I do feel
confident in such things plus we have
really great stories today I mean the
world literally the second we stopped
recording I'm uploading yesterday's
episode people notification people
notification people notifications
rolling in and then the biggest news of
all
the new Spritz flavor the new Spritz
flavor dropped today when this episode
is up it will be available to shop at
spritzociety.com Clawson pickle now
let's give a little back story because
people were like wait I'm having Deja Vu
is this real are you pranking us again
two years ago and I literally told Ben
this was gonna happen last year no it
was two years ago two years yeah last
year like not this past April April
before Oh I guess okay then it's like a
year and a half
um two April fools ago we did like on
April Fool's joke like our new flavor is
pickle and I'm like Ben I'm telling you
I think people are actually gonna want
that he's like no it'll be funny I'm
like okay I know nothing not a
businesswoman you know what do I know
I'm just a slowly housewife
and of course we announced it people
were like I know this is April Fool's
but like is it weird that I'm devastated
you know pickle the pickle Community is
strong and either you get it or you
don't and so that led us on our journey
to being like I think we actually have
to do this so we actually reached out to
a bunch of pickle brands and Clawson was
so excited about it Clawson is kind of
like the most iconic pickle like the jar
is so recognizable and they were like
let's do it like let's make a pickle
wine and we did it took a really long
time to like get the formula right
because it's a very um it's a delicate
thing it's a yeah it's a acquired taste
you don't like me acquire some taste so
we can now officially launch today at
noon by the time this episode comes out
it'll already be up at spritzociety.com
claussenpickles our pickle wine now I
know a lot of people saying Claudia
there's no way that you would drink this
and to that I say you know you'll have
to wait and see the taste test that we
filmed you filmed a taste test you'll
have to wait and see you know I'm not
gonna spoil it it'll be available on our
socials you know you'll just have to
wait and see I have not tried this yet
obviously what hi why Jackie is there
something you want to share with the
class
um so um 34 weeks today but I've smelled
it and it smells so good I love pickles
oh and a fun fact about me
up until this moment I'd never had a
pickle
did you do a tick tock yeah of course
no no having the pickle Spritz
oh for sure but you also need to have a
pickle maybe I'll add that to my list
have a closet and I mean it doesn't get
better than Clawson no it doesn't and it
helps that it kind of sounds like
Claudia
I knew that this partnership was
speaking to me for a specific reason but
I couldn't figure out why so at Sprint
society.com pickle it's only available
online it is super limited so like
pickle girl ladies get in line yeah
um so that's kind of what's making today
like big headline headline news what
else is making today headline news
Jackson Claude back in studio Jackson
Claude back in the studio it's a
pleasure to be here so so great that
you're here I know it takes a lot for
you to get here we really appreciate it
yeah no but it's good I feel my best in
the mornings I just deteriorate
throughout the day by the evening like I
cannot move it's so crazy I can't even
sit on the couch comfortably I could
barely lay in bed comfortably that's
just sounds terrible it's horrible and
then sleep is restorative in the morning
it's like is it good sleep
it's been good sleep last night wasn't
great because Harry woke up and slept
with us which was amazing oh my God you
know Harry not to make everything about
me hurry slept with me one time he did
in the night oh he took a nap on me once
and it wasn't even a scheduled nap he
just felt so safe and comfortable in the
arms of his auntie he just passed out he
also like had him watching a movie and
and do not diminish do not diminish the
Napper around the world like that is
something I will not stand for okay I
won't I'm gonna ask you something crazy
have a sip of your water sure let me
take one step first and then you'll
never sip it again no no just in case I
didn't no I'll do a waterfall okay but
but that just made me thirsty oh okay oh
speaking of thirsty and this is like not
a dig towards anyone I don't know if you
saw it did you see that Bethany and Joe
released a podcast episode together I
saw that they were going to it came out
last night I listened to like a little
bit of it this morning just to like see
what the Vibes were and it was very much
like you know Bethany in charge Jill
groveling like Bethany tilling Jill
everything she did wrong how she fumbled
the bag as a housewife she could have
been a star it was a kind of mean that's
crazy no granted I didn't listen to the
whole episode they were talking about
um just like their Journey at a glance
and I don't know it felt like I mean how
many times we're gonna beat Jill down
for like yeah okay
15 years later I know I was like it was
a Time Warp for sure oh that's crazy did
they talk about the new show
I didn't they might have I didn't get
there
uh also the new show in the five minutes
that I watched like a big topic of
conversation is one of the girls Aaron
plans to group dinner for the group and
two of the girls don't go because the
restaurant she chose is like not
attacking yeah and they kept beeping out
the restaurant they don't want to be
sued
I don't know I could suit for saying
what like it's not crazy it's not cool
anymore it's past its prime anyways I
didn't like care too much what the
restaurant was I figured it was like
something like Bagatelle or something I
don't know somewhat placed I don't have
connection to a connection to and
instead the two girls went to Casa
chibriani and now it's emerging that the
restaurant they were talking about is
Catch and I just take that [__]
personally so I mean what were they
saying about catch is it entirely
factually incorrect no to be honest I
feel like it makes the girls look I I
don't I didn't watch the episode I
cannot tell any tell you anyone's name
except for Uber my queen and of course
Jenna Lions all the other girls they're
all Britain they're all
um yes whatever like they're all the
girls like I don't know but the ones who
were like ragging and like not going to
a dinner like it makes like in my
opinion I know they're trying to be
funny and like you know Elite Housewives
of New York it makes them look like
losers just go to the dinner right and
also it's like catch was really popular
and trendy she was like it's not 2000
2005 anymore yeah um it was really
popular and trendy but it's also really
good like even though it's not at its
height right now like you go the food's
good the music the vibe is good and by
the way I'm sure that they are limited
in the restaurants that they can film at
they didn't they weren't filming Aaron
said she just couldn't get like a big
reservation
somewhere yeah we love cats no by the
way catch literally raised us we were
literally spending every weekend there
when we were in college but no I mean
that's literally what they're saying no
I know but even now like when we would
have a gno like a year ago we would go
to catch no but if I'm trying to meet a
new group of girls like one of like
whatever we just are picking a place to
go eat and like a few of the girls won't
be seen at that restaurant like nobody
cares more about image than me and like
even I think that's like so extreme yeah
and like really mean yeah to the girl
who planned it and undeserving of catch
I feel like there are other restaurants
that are really over hyped that like
maybe we're trendy at one point but
weren't actually good yeah like catches
the goods no I completely agree I saw
this whole Saga and I think it's
actually good because I don't know if
anyone would have like cared that much
about the Roni reboot but this is like
an interesting storyline everyone trying
to figure out and maybe that's why they
did it to create Intrigue about what
restaurant it was but it's got me
interested uh justice for catch is all I
want to say I love catch even still and
yes back in the day that's what they're
saying it was cool back in the day and
we used to go all the time but every
time I go still and they have catch
steak now we just always have the best
time no and what are we always saying
things are popular for a reason
and capture I think is a prime example
of that well it may not be the coolest
spot now like good is good food good
food is good food good vibes Are Good
Vibes yeah
good drinks good drinks like good
everything yeah
okay so Beyonce's not gonna be there do
you even want to eat next to Beyonce no
one would be looking at you
that's true and instead they went to
Casa Cipriani which like okay is so cool
members only like I just like I kind of
hate people like that like so like too
cool for school you want to go to a
restaurant like one night at a
restaurant that's not my favorite
restaurant and they might not even be
like that in real life maybe they're
trying to put that out for the show
which isn't even more losery 100 so you
know what maybe I'll watch yeah I wanted
to finish the episode but I couldn't sit
on the couch anymore because my butt
hurt and my back hurt and my belly hurt
uh so I didn't I watched a little bit of
young Sheldon I finally finished my
non-fiction book Jenny by Ralph Martin I
think it was a thousand Pages damn I
started in December I was reading it for
weeks in December it's like a biography
about Churchill's mother you probably if
you were listening to toastness Emery
probably remember me talking oh I do I
do remember Jenny yeah Jenny yeah I read
it for a few weeks in December but then
I was like I'm making no Headway I need
to reach my Goodreads goals like I need
to that's real I need to move on with my
life that's so real so I shelved it for
a while you young Sheldon I young
shelved it then last month there was a
historical fiction book about her that
Churchill woman so I was like let me
read that I clearly was not
at the level of the book I thought I was
I read that and I found it lacking I was
like I need the real story I need to buy
it back to the OJ I went back to the OG
and like every night I've been
challenging myself to read at least one
chapter and I finally finished it and
how good does it feel it feels so good
to have that marked off and not sitting
on my current really reading like that
should really count as two on Goodreads
you know I know something like that but
then you also have small wins where
Cambrian counselor counts Jessica
Simpson's you know chapter Jessica
Simpson's 30-page book
um I also read last night I read the
book for my book club
um what's it called happy place by Emily
Henry I went into it with a bad attitude
like really horrible like I I think
Emily Henry books are really over hyped
um and not me like being 50 of the way
through and absolutely loving it so much
so to the point where I couldn't put it
down wait I'm in shock I finish it
I
I can't recall a time in recent memory
where somebody is so fumbled like the
second half of the book was the worst
book I ever read like it was shocking I
felt like I picked up another book I
tried to sleep and I couldn't sleep I'm
like all right let me finish it I felt
like I picked up another book I was
shocked so you didn't like it no no no
oh my god wow this has been a journey
yeah no it was a journey like I went
into it such a hater
changed my mind and it's like you know
she was right to hate
that's kind of the lesson like trust
your instinct yeah well I finished it
you were at the club and I feel like you
know you'll be able to participate in
book club another one off the Goodreads
where are you at in your 2020. oh that's
a great question I'm definitely halfway
I think I'm on track
I'm on track if not but I didn't include
campaign counselor like but you've read
it I guess I have include it treat
yourself you think yeah 100 I am at 28.
I'm at 28 also but you have two cheats
in there not to be rude and you're all
your books are [__] cheap no they're
not all your books are cheap they're not
they're not [__] rude don't be
[__] rude all your books are cheats
like we're not the same
yeah we're not I don't put children's
books on my Goodreads you just read
children's books everybody
I don't think the children it's
appropriate for them to read what I read
no certainly not so they're not
children's books certainly not but you
read like PDFs
wow PDFs not true I read Scholastic
works of art sure
so that's what I did last night and
that's what you did last night what's
your goal for the year Well it
automatically sets to 50 but I have to
beat last year last year I did 60.
mine's 40. you're well on your way and
you're going to be in like your
breastfeeding postpartum era like I
think you'll I didn't read a lot last
time in that era um just brains turned
off brain is turned off for business we
were so busy we recorded a podcast
episode for the patreon if you want to
go listen to it General q a we haven't
caught up with everyone like people you
know we've been you know modeling doing
so many things everyone's like you know
trying to keep up with us so we just
caught up with everyone General q and
A's are the patrons we've done polls
they're the favorite type of episode
that we do you can ask those questions
about like any topic anything and things
are popular for a reason and things are
popular for a reason so we really got
into a bunch of different stuff and it
was really fun it was a busy day
yesterday I spent a lot of time with
Harry what's better than that nothing
right nothing nothing and he was like
kind of would you say taken with me yeah
he was enjoying his time we were all
coloring it was amazing you like
bogarted his coloring book yeah until
like Harry put the crown in his mouth
and then it was like he had nowhere else
to put it because you took kids I like
low-key love to color and not this like
adult Coloring Book Like No I like
simple children's colors just like
Mindless coloring just doodling maybe I
do like children's books
maybe I do maybe you do
full circle
mindless doodling it is really nice it's
good so it takes the brain you know to
creative places yeah it was nice it was
nice it was a gorgeous day oh you know
I I walked a lot yesterday because like
I met I had a lunch and then I whatever
I was walking around and I'm like this
might be the first time in my life like
I'll actually do 10 000 steps okay I
walked so much
not me getting into bed in like 6 500.
how the [__] do they tell people to walk
10 000 steps a day like I have a very
you know flexible job a flexible life
are people who walk 10 000 steps a day
unemployed like seriously where are they
doing that I don't know Zach used to
take so many steps in the day but he
also like Paces a lot um like that
shouldn't count but it does but it does
yeah but you like aside from that walk
that you did those two big Walks Like
You are sedentary the entire day all
right most people like we have to work I
guess not okay yesterday I had let me
look my step count is abysmal right now
what was yesterday as it should be
yesterday was Monday 6 700 and like when
I tell you I walked all day
yeah I'm sorry so and I watched well
over a mile so we were supposed to be
walking over a mile a day I guess so but
also Studies have come out that this 10
000 step count thing is like the
extremely arbitrary it was like a
marketing tool well that Fitbit for sure
and I also don't really understand like
I don't believe that my phone is truly
like a perfect pedometer it's not and
like sometimes you go to the bathroom
without your phone like you forget it
there's a couple steps yeah but it's
like you're counting on your bathroom
steps to get you to ten thousand like
you're so far off everything counts and
with the frequency I go to the bathroom
well you yes I deserve those you should
wear a pedometer then like a Fitbit or
an Apple Watch I used to wear an aura
ring right then I lost it right
but yeah if you want more accurate step
count
get a
tracker thing get a grip what are the
wearable tech
right that was a crazy time when like
everyone was wearing fitbits it was like
the biggest baddest thing and everyone
was just like monitoring their hearts
all the time that's what people do with
Apple watch now yeah but let's see if it
started it whoop and then remember like
there was that study that came out that
like after like years of foot Fitbit
popularity and like literally everyone
owning a Fitbit that um people were
actually gaining weight no and like all
of the data was completely inaccurate oh
no I didn't see that I saw that people
were actually gaining weight because
they like they had always been taking
these this amount of steps was tracking
it no it's like oh I took so many steps
today
oh well they were always doing that yeah
I love when like you know
kind of ubiquitous Health Trends become
you know
the opposite no no what's the word um
debunked yeah perfect debunked like
remember when everyone was eating kind
bars and then like years later there was
a study that set of kind bar is actually
just suspending for years of Snickers so
all of us who were choosing Snickers
over kind Mars the last few years were
kind of Vindicated yeah I never liked a
kind bar me neither and I love a bar
perfect bar I know macro I know Fiber
One I I like people kind bar is like a
cult not enough people talk about that
they're too chewy gives me a headache
it's just like
it's just not good you know no it's not
and that's kind of where I draw the line
for snacks it's too hard it's too hard
reformulate so we've got a great show I
mean there's quite literally so much to
talk about yeah and I think we quite
literally should get into have no choice
other than to get into the fast five
stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
neutralfall did you know that hair
thinning will happen to approximately
one in two women if you're among them no
you're not alone the thinning is normal
and neutral helps women address it from
the science-backed supplements from
neutralfall so it is a number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement it is clinically shown to
improve visible thickness and strength
so whatever reason you might be
experiencing hair thinning I know a lot
of women experience it postpartum
menopause no matter what stage in life
neutral has four unique formulas to
support women each is physician
formulated using drug-free
science-backed ingredients so you get
the most reliable results so when you
start your neutral Journey you go to
neutralfall.com you take their health
hair Health quiz
identify causes of your thinning hair
and go to neutralfall it'll personalize
a plan for you to get better hair growth
through their whole body health approach
you know I'm sure you can notice because
I'm wearing my hair up today like I have
been experiencing hair thinning it for
me I know when I took the hair quiz I
realized it was for my like I had a
total change in diet over the last year
and it's totally normal to go through
hair thinning
um and when I was talking about this
everyone was like you got to take
neutrophone it's kind of like everyone
knows it's like all the cool kids are
doing it
um so neutrophone supports healthy hair
growth from within by targeting root
causes of thinning which can be stress
hormones environment nutrition lifestyle
metabolism and they do that through
whole body health so take the first step
to visibly thicker healthier hair for
limited time neutrophil is offering our
listeners ten dollars off your first
month subscription and free shipping
when you go to neutrophone.com and enter
the promo code the toast find out why
over 4 000 Healthcare professionals
recommend neutrophil for healthier hair
neutral
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code the toast
that's neutralfall.com promo code the
toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by modern fertility think back to sex ed
for a moment you probably learned all
about how to prevent pregnancy but what
about how to plan for it we've always
been been big fans of planning ahead
like scheduling trips months in advance
plotting out our next big career moves
figuring out what we're doing for dinner
while still eating breakfast but some of
us have never thought much about you
know planning for kids and that's why
modern fertility was created it's easy
and affordable and it's a way to test
your fertility hormones at home with a
simple finger prick mail it in with a
prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within six business
days you get insights into your hormone
levels like your ovarian reserve other
important factors that can impact your
fertility the results go deep into what
every hormone means and you can also
download the results to review with your
doctor for next steps traditional
hormone testing at a fertility clinic
can cost over six hundred dollars but
modern fertility tests the same general
set of hormones for only 179 dollars and
if you go to modernfertility.com toast
you can get 20 off your test also you
can get reimbursed for the test through
FSA or your HSA right now modern
fertility is offering our listeners 20
off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that means
your test will cost 159 dollars which is
a fraction of what it would cost at a
fertility clinic get 20 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that's
modernfertility.com toast if you want
kids today or maybe one day in the
future clinically sound information
about your body it can help you make the
decision that's right for you it's so
easy it's so much more affordable and
you know information is never a bad
thing to have you know knowledge is
power that's what I was trying to say
but I couldn't think of like the phrase
thank you yeah welcome yeah welcome our
first story is some major news beauty
news which is some of my favorite news
perfect for two beautiful girls as I
look at you I'm inspired to share beauty
news that's so generous of you thank you
would you say it's beauty news that's
beautiful stunning and smart
yes about a girly swirly who's beautiful
stunning and smart it's like major news
in the beauty modeling industry and
shockingly it's not about us no but we
have a way to make it about us that is
what's I think most exciting about this
story because we've been knowing this
news for a few days now before it no not
a few days I would say like maybe a week
and a half well your perception of time
is also very true also very true so
maybe let's settle on a week week and a
half we've known this news for a while
and we're so excited to share our first
story is actually brought to you by
L'Oreal Paris because Kendall Jenner has
been named their new international
spokesperson for L'Oreal Paris so I just
have to say I love this I think this is
such a get for L'Oreal and such a get
for Kendall like L'Oreal is the biggest
most internationally recognized Beauty
brand Kettle is really like the biggest
model of our time currently and so this
partnership makes a lot of sense I love
things that make a lot of sense the
photos from the photo shoot are like
sickening stunning she's wearing this
kind of like high-end sweatshirt that
we're also wearing today only really
fashionable girls can wear no it's kind
of like a sweatshirt made exclusively
for models yeah and so you know me you
Kendall like it makes sense it makes
sense I love this I think this is so
smart on L'Oreal's part so smart she's
the new Fox she's got a gorgeous Fox yep
and L'Oreal she's worth it uh because
I'm worth it I mean we are worth it
let's just let's get that out of the way
yeah um and what I love about this is I
read that like Mary Phillips who is
Kendall's makeup artist was like really
involved in the photo shoot and Mary
Phillips is like so iconic her like
underpainting tutorial went viral on
Tech talk I tried it it was like under
paintings when you Contour underneath
you contour and highlight underneath
your foundation so like you're really
contouring from within now when it's you
know Mary Phillips says that it's
absolutely gorgeous beautiful setting
smart when I did it I looked like I
literally rubbed dirt on my face but
like I think it just takes some practice
so like a lot of like The Tick Tock
beauty trends are involved I think it's
really smart I love Mary Phillips she's
so talented I actually needed to do that
this morning I was looking at my face
and I was like I need Contour but I
needed it under my Foundation
underpainting is the method and honestly
it's so difficult to I watched like a
thousand tutorials to master but if you
do it's like really the key to wearing
no makeup while looking snatched but
you're wearing like so much makeup you
know that's so awesome well I think this
is news that makes sense yep love that
it's beautiful news I'm happy for
Kendall I look forward to seeing her
face everywhere such a delight we're
always saying you know what if Kendall
wore it yeah what if we saw Kendall in
this Kendall doing that and like just to
be in airports buses everything like NC
Kendall planes bus Club another club bus
works for me works for me I love this I
think this is so major you know big
moves on on the Kardashians part big
moves on L'Oreal's part yeah also what's
really exciting and what's even better
is that L'Oreal is giving you the chance
to win a trip of a lifetime an all
expenses trip for two to Paris for Paris
Fashion Week wow to enter maybe me and
you should enter and go you know what
kind of sounds like it sounds like it's
a Passport to Paris literally to enter
all you have to do is go to their
website and enter to win by filling out
the L'Oreal Paris trip to Paris giveaway
form the giveaway is only open for two
weeks so you better go now do not forget
to go sign up for the sweepstakes live
your best Parisian life
is that Italian no that was the point
yeah all that don't forget to sign up
we'll leave a link in our podcast
description for the website and signing
up so it'll be super easy and if a
toaster gets picked to go to Paris like
need a plus one
shot no I think you'll be like you know
busy I'll deserve it because of how busy
I've been no I mean I I see I see your
point however no I think we should sign
up together yes but if a toaster wins
like I am available and happy for you
know that I am know that I am and I'm
happy for L'Oreal I'm happy for Kendall
this is great news to start off the day
agreed okay next story it's a twofer
because we have two big celebrity
couples who are divorcing as of
yesterday back to back first we have
Ariana Grande and her husband Dalton
Gomez who have separated saying we
couldn't make it work in a post-covered
world sources connected to the former
couple with direct knowledge tell TMZ
that when Aryan Dalton hooked up in 2020
they were everything to each other
company romance support all of it and
when coveted restrictions lifted their
differences became alarmingly impa
apparent Dalton who's a realtor was
taken aback by Ariana's celebrity he had
not dealt with her schedule the
paparazzi and the various opportunities
that took her out of La all of this to
say they could not make it work you know
with her being so busy you know what
it's giving
lies well for sure but you know what
else it's giving
this guy drilling conflict max air click
like civilian dating a celeb and can't
handle it buckles under the pressure
could not hack it I mean like I said
yesterday I'm not heartbroken like I
don't know this man he's like so
irrelevant to me and this kind of being
like Ari's brand like literally Seven
Rings like I'm kind of here for the
seven husbands of Ariana Grande like I'm
here for Ari to like continue to get
married and like divorced yeah but
what's crazy is this was actually just
her first marriage well second
engagement second engagement yeah and
you know she had like such a a big love
with Mac right and with Big Sean
honestly like I really ship I know Big
Sean is like so happy but I really do
ship I feel like you know what I'm like
kind of living for this I kind of wish
she had married all of them right when
she was dating them right I feel what
you're saying completely I think this is
a load of horror [__] like how do you
marry on Ariana Grande and not expect
her to be busy I also feel like even
though she's filming a movie in London
right now
that busy so true there was a time where
she was not sleeping like she was album
twice a year bus club like just the
busiest girl in the world now she has
like this one steady gig that's gonna
take her years in London to film and
like he could be there with her if you
want to doing real estate but he doesn't
it's clear that he doesn't want to be
there it's so true this is probably like
the most stable few years Ariana's
Ariana's gonna have just given her
schedule like she's not touring she's
not releasing music so it's really just
kind of like a day job yeah and that's
like a blessing I feel like projects
like this when you live that life so he
couldn't even hack it now she's in one
place right like you're shocked I don't
know I mean if he's it could be a lie if
it's the truth it's like pathetic sure
relationships are different in kovid
versus out of covert but then to be
surprised by her celebrity outside like
lies no I'm just like the lie detector
determined that was a lie so true
I am incredibly here for this breakup I
think this really adds to Ariana's kind
of air of mystery and her brand is like
a powerful woman and I hope she
continues to fall in love you know as
many times as she wants to as many times
as she needs to right as as many times
as time will allow her you know and keep
getting divorced keep getting engaged
like I'm I love it yeah but I also think
that he misbehaved like I think that if
he had acted right they would still be
married I don't think this is what she
wanted no this isn't like a plan of hers
it's just a nice side effect no it's not
like she like just intentionally married
someone to get over him in a few years
like I think he didn't behave and like
that's unacceptable when you're married
to Ariana Grande who's not only so
successful but she's so gorgeous and
like adorable [__] behave who are you
going out with instead when you could be
home with Ari in London
I said yesterday that I had seen some
blinds that he was you know [__]
around others I saw a story today that
he's already like seeing other people
and it's like who do you think you are
who the hell do you think you are
Kelly's new album I mean you don't have
to tell me twice a fellow divorce say
maybe oh did you see that and they're
friends from The Voice yes they're not
only are they friends they have deep
admiration and respect for one another
yeah and they can out sing each other
yeah it's unclear who's a better
songstress
it's really unclear no like some people
would say Ari some people would say
Kelly as a fan of both them I actually
don't know who I would say neither of
those people would be wrong no in some
ways it's like I want to say Ari because
she's the voice of a generation but like
Kelly [__] slays so I think if I had
to choose
I would say that Ari is a more skilled
vocalist and Kelly is still an extremely
skilled vocalist but where she has
already beat is songwriting agreed but
you you can underestimate Kelly's vocal
no you can't I know and you really like
think of all the bangers all right like
you really can't underestimate ARA
songwriting abilities it's too much and
that's why they respect one another so
much they know that neither one of them
has anything over on the other yeah and
that's why when they perform together
they just like keep riffing on top of
each other but it's not in a competitive
way it's just like let us do our thing I
hope that these two can lean on each
other through these difficult times I
agree though I have to add her to the
list yes and see who's waiting for her
on the list on the other side though she
never goes for the obvious choice and up
until this point I think it's gotten her
like far like you know I I now Pete
Davidson is an obvious choice but Ariana
made him the obvious choice he was not
an obvious choice neither was Mac Miller
so she kind of makes you know men out of
boys yeah
Jeremy Allen White oh my God even though
you know he's rumored to be dating
Selena Gomez oh no I didn't know yeah
but obsessed with him too and and I'm
looking Ari who on this list is like
Aries I read a rumor no one for her here
I read a rumor that like is completely
unsubstantiated but that Taylor might be
releasing a remix to one of her Vault
songs you're losing me
um
with Ari why I don't know someone just
said it so they have a relationship I
don't know actually no because like Ari
so scooter Brawn I feel like Taylor
would never oh I just I debunked the
rumor yeah I created the rumor and
debunked it all in one Ari and Taylor
have like never acknowledged each other
once right not negative or positive you
know yeah oh you know speaking of I
forget if you you were on the toast
maybe CBT when we were talking about
lizzo and it was me and Taylor I think
so did you see there was like another
interaction this weekend Liza was at a
concert and somebody had a sign that
said like I chose to be here you know
over Taylor and lizzo like picked the
sign up like signed it and was like
there's no beef but like picking up the
sign that like is putting down another
artist like kind of fuels the fire of
the beef yeah I also think that lizzo
probably saw the feedback that like she
has beef with Taylor and doesn't want
she's not that kind of artist so she
probably wanted to debunk the beef thing
but I'm not like no if anything um my
fire is more fueled than ever I feel the
same as I felt where it's like there's
probably something yeah but I also
understand her wanting to squash it but
not knowing how because it's
unsquashable because it's real here
unsquashable
what song is that
your Irreplaceable without re-singing I
don't know
that's good too that's good too I want
to know what you were saying
how many had soldiers that sounds like
what you're singing have you known
sitting down before
maybe Irreplaceable but sing it again
what you were singing you're
unsquashable no you're singing something
else
sound off in the comments what am I
saying
I feel like someone's gonna know it
sounds like kind of familiar yeah one
more time here unsquashable I think your
Irreplaceable now you're changing it to
like no okay I'm consistent okay
I think let me know what you think
you're consistent and I read children's
books part two of The Breakup news of
the breakup news this is devastating is
that Sophia Vergara and Joe manganello
are divorcing after seven years of
marriage Paige cisks can exclusively
reveal the couple said in a statement
quote we have made the difficult
decision to divorce as two people that
love and care for one another very much
we politely ask for respect of our
privacy at this time as we navigate this
new phase of Our Lives
this was really difficult for me for a
multitude of reasons I don't know if you
know this Sofia Vergara is a birthday
buddy of mine
sounds familiar but I'm glad that you
get it gave us that context so I'm not
like her number one fan but I definitely
feel a kinship yeah and I feel like I
was so invested in her journey with Joe
manginello because
he's so [__] hot like I I watch True
Blood like he's literally the hottest
man on the planet like no one hotter has
ever been born it's just a fact except
for Me Maybe
um so like it's always exciting to see
who someone like that is going to be
with and Sophia Vergara is like
obviously the most beautiful woman in
the world but she wasn't like an obvious
choice you know and like they're so
different you know and I was so happy
for them especially because I think that
they meant during a really difficult
period in her life where like her
ex-husband was like suing her for their
embryos it was like really like a
disgusting thing for a human being to do
and I think that you'll comfort her
comforted her in that time and I loved
how he was there for her and I've always
felt like a real um like Observer to
their journey and I thought they were
really happy and they were never like
thirsty or even really spotted out
together which made us you know believe
in their love even more they're not
doing it for the cameras so I kind of
forgot about them which is a good sign
in a Hollywood relationship so for the
next thing I hear to be them breaking up
it's absolutely devastating like I was
really really crushed
so I feel a little differently about it
and I love them as a couple and they
make so much sense and they're just like
Hollywood A-list Perfection but I feel
like we got what we needed from this
relationship like they don't have kids
together right seven years in Hollywood
it's like you know 21 years dog years
like that's a long successful marriage
they no longer serve each other they get
to go back on the market and we get to
see them with other people like I've got
what I needed
no I'm sorry like
if it couldn't be me I'm glad it was her
you know and I don't want it to be
anyone else
that's right I never know maybe he'll
pick someone me
is that like you also love me show and
also if they're divorcing like they're
obviously I'm happy with each other
they'll be happier elsewhere add them to
the list oh yeah is there any I mean
okay wait I got it I got it I got it Joe
manchinello and Ari Joe manginello and
Khloe Kardashian like sorry that's
actually perfect you're right I could
learn to love again right right see it's
fun no it is but like I really I will be
mourning the loss of this relationship I
think they were like a kind of a pillar
in their Community I agree and it's hard
when like you lose a pillar because
that's the foundation like and we've
lost a lot of pillars over the years
yeah and the whole thing could come
crumbling down yeah if we continue to
lose no it's
it's definitely a tough break but you've
kind of made me see like there are there
is a possibility for happiness on the
other side yeah and like they weren't
like you said they weren't giving us
anything so it's not like on the
day-to-day I was like reminded of that
they're together and yeah but if they
were giving us stuff we would have
started to hate them you know
eventually like you always are just like
all right it's enough yeah even when you
love like a couple
I don't know this was it was shocking
even though a lot of people were like I
knew did you see what he posted for her
birthday like
okay
eye roll
um I didn't know and I'm devastated I'm
sorry if you just think of Chloe just
think of Chloe
no is it like they're actually perfect
for each other
he's
quite literally the hottest man or Kim
no no
no I'm thinking like real personality
even though I've never met Joe
mangionella or even like seen him in
anything that wasn't like a role I have
like a strong feeling that they would
really connect on like a personality
level I feel like he's kind of goofy but
he's also like a strong silent type like
I don't know I just it's he gives me
like energy from one of the characters
of my book in my books you know oh for
sure and he also played that in True
Blood which is where I learned about him
um he was kind of just like stoic like
hot like hero
um like I'm obsessed and I know
everybody thinks of him now probably for
Magic Mike right not I I then this
movie's never connected with me me
neither
um
nevertheless I still love him yeah
okay well it could be like when people
ask me my celebrity crush like I never
say him but like he really is like one
of them yeah
just seems like a solid citizen yeah and
like a nice guy All-American Vibe you
know throwing a football around nice
looking yeah
are you ready for our next story
definitely Miranda Lambert has been
blasted for stopping a concert to call
out fans for taking a selfie I'm
obsessed okay so Miranda Lambert was
performing a concert this weekend I
believe in Vegas right she has a
residency there yeah and the picture the
subsequent picture was giving Vegas
residency Vegas outfits um and someone
posted on Tick Tock a video of her
stopping singing her song tin man to say
quote I'm gonna stop right here for a
second I'm sorry these girls are worried
about their selfie and not listening to
the song it's pissing me off a little
bit she added that she did not like
their behavior at all we're here to hear
some country music I'm singing some damn
country music while some fans cheered in
the footage others walked out of the
show one could be heard saying let's go
you don't do that to fans however some
fans are Stan and social media users are
standing by Miranda other people are
like you know that's not cool and the
women who took the picture has spoken
have spoken they posted their picture
um
to Instagram and of course the internet
found out who these [__] were like in
35 seconds flocked to the photo left
comments on their on their Instagram so
funny that and all the pictures like
they had their group photo which I guess
is one they got stopped for but they
also each had like solo shots with like
Miranda in the back they're obviously
really big fans they spoke to NBC News
and said quote it felt like I was back
at school with the teacher scolding me
for doing something wrong and telling me
to sit back down in my place I feel like
she was determined to make us look like
we were young immature in vain but we're
just grown women in our 30s to 60s
trying to take a picture oh oh my God
she said we took the picture quickly and
we were going to sit back down they said
the group couldn't get one good picture
before the show started so she asked
someone to take their photo towards the
end of the concert we were so excited
because I think we had the best seats in
the House in the whole theater well that
also makes it worse because she's
staring at you guys the whole time right
but like they spent the money like yeah
so we were talking about this yesterday
like what do we think and on the one
like overall it's like they spend the
money they bought the tickets however
they want to spend their time is how
they're going to spend their time and
like they're taking selfies like they're
excited to be there promoting you you
know like yeah like and also first of
all they weren't taking a selfie in this
picture because the selfie implies that
they're ignoring Miranda and they're
focused on themselves yeah but in the
picture they all turned around so
Miranda could get in the background of
the photo right and so Miranda is still
the feature the focus of the picture and
it's there and especially since they're
like older women like I'm sure you know
it's hard for them to get I understand
but I also Miranda doesn't know all of
that she doesn't know they couldn't get
their picture before the show they love
Miranda they're in their 60s they're
just trying to get a cute photo like
she's just seeing it from her perch on
the stage where it's like these girls
have their backs turned to me they're
focused on taking pictures who knows how
many pictures they took they have the
best seats in the house she has to look
at only them and they're not focused on
her now does that make what she did
right no no by the way Miranda in her
brain has absolutely every right to be
like oh these [__] women like you can
it's definitely like as a performer like
somebody ignoring you like hello I'm
standing right here uh to call them out
is so in my opinion like unequivocally
wrong not only is it like humiliating
for people who probably flew to most
people for Vegas residencies they fly to
see you
flew all the way spend all the money
like are probably so excited they got
the best seats like they're obviously
huge fans to call them out and embarrass
them is so mean-spirited and like so
unnecessary and not to say that like was
she wrong for for her opinion no she was
wrong for sharing it yeah like it's
humiliating and then to rile up the
crowd she's like I want to sing some
country music and like getting everybody
to be like yeah yeah like it's
humiliating it's mean it's unnecessary
and you know this is I've been on a
journey with Miranda Lambert like I
really did not understand her as a woman
as an artist many years ago and I've
kind of fallen in love with her over the
last few years like I just I get her now
I don't get this yeah it's a little
overboard in terms of how she handled it
and also taking pictures is kind of like
the fun of a concert like you take
pictures you take videos like it's just
it's not that crazy but on the other
hand like I feel like comedians do this
all the time like someone even takes
their phone out to send a text if you're
even allowed to have your phone and they
will call you out okay and that's like
yeah go off okay I have two rebuttals to
that one a part of Comedy culture and
like going to a comedy show is knowing
at any time you could be called on like
you're kind of agreeing to like this
unspoken social contract like if I'm
going to a comedy club like I could very
well be picked on like you you some
people go because they love that one two
a part of also comedy culture is phones
being not allowed like in the age of
social media I think everyone who like
is a fan of a comedian knows like I'm
not going to record a set and put it
online I'm not gonna be on my phone like
it's completely different whereas
concert culture kind of thrives off of
videos going viral and performances
being shown all over the world it's two
totally different cultures I don't think
that's a fair comparison okay
well maybe Miranda wants her shows to
kind of be a culture where you just sit
and listen to some damn country music
well I feel like you have to put that
out there you have to say like you know
in an interview or you know before the
show be like listen remember when Lord
unplugged her microphone and told
everybody to shh so she could sing
without the microphone and have
everybody hear her like that was a weird
ass thing but her fans going in knew
that that was what she does because
she's put that out there okay so I think
this is a good lesson for Miranda fans
like Miranda doesn't want to see you on
your phone okay
but it's still this was way harsh Ty it
way harsh Ty Frazier yeah it was not a
good look for Miranda and now by the way
like and this is what happens this is
just the nature of like internet culture
is anytime she's like had any kind of
like other weird
um on stage moments are there being
broadcast like I saw you know at
concerts a lot of the times people like
throw around beach balls and like they
tap it to one part of the crowd and go
see another and it landed on stage and
she literally got a knife and deflated
like she's got enough for sure but the
thing I'll say about this story is I
actually don't think it's that damaging
to her because it's not my favorite word
in congress with how I Envision her
personality Bad Gal energy yeah like I
with the Ben Platt thing I'm so glad you
brought that up yes it was like he
showcases himself as like this affable
loving person theater loving art critic
like yeah but it turns out behind the
scenes like he's a little bit answer
questions and he can't take a joke he's
throwing things at his apartment but
Miranda Lambert like is serious about
music like she's not is she even on
social media like she's like the bad
girl of country she doesn't give a [__]
you're right that's and amazing point so
I don't think this harms her brand
that's an amazing point oh and I'm sorry
like if somebody else got embarrassed at
a concert I was at like I would never
leave like if I got embarrassed for sure
I would leave but somebody else would be
like okay that was weird but like I paid
for these tickets I'm still gonna watch
a show yeah no I wouldn't have left over
this like I would have thought that if
you were the girls would you have left
who got yelled at
um
I would have like I would have like
probably cried
I don't know I would have been like
mortified and then there I've been
talking to NBC and saying it felt like
they were at the principal's office
that's the perfect like that is what it
feels like they did come all this way no
I know and like they're clearly such big
fans so how do you kind of grapple those
two realities yeah I really felt bad for
these girlies like they just looked like
Funtime girls they were just looking for
a good time I know like it's a little
way to Vegas you know girls trip and
when you're like older you don't get
those opportunities like life gets in
the way oh and that's the other place to
go to a concert a week now I don't even
to a concert in years this show also
being in Vegas is like an important
factor like Vegas is extra special and
extra kind of kooky like things happen
in Vegas they fly in Vegas that would
never happen in Portland you know like
it's an important factor like
I don't know she's she's wrong for this
yeah but she doesn't give a [__] but
your your point about her just kind of
being like the Bad Gal of Country and
this being completely congress with like
the reputation she has is a really like
this isn't going to damage her brand
this isn't going to harm sales yeah I
agree like the people who love her still
want to see her they're going to put
their phones away yeah and you know what
I feel like for Miranda that's a win
that's kind of what she wanted
good because it's the one you got like
I'm sure everyone around her today is
like Miranda what do we want to say and
she's like I don't give a [__] yeah
don't use your don't take your selfies
yeah no I don't like I think like her
publicist is probably like losing her
mind Miranda's sleeping sound like
Miranda couldn't be bothered to care
agreed and you know what that's why
she's the bad guy with country like Bad
Gal reread bad girl Mimi it's true
are you ready for our next story no
you're not no do I look ready
I just wasn't picking up on social cues
well this is not the first time today's
episode of the toast is brought to you
by eBay authenticity guarantee Jackie
and I love to invest whether it's purses
clothing shoes we are always making sure
to shop smart with eBay authenticity
guarantee eBay authenticators are there
verifying every detail of your purchase
so eBay authenticity guarantee protects
buyers from fakes and it gives them the
assurance that they're getting the real
deal because what's worse than spending
time and money and energy scouring the
internet for your next investment only
to later find out that you have been
scammed with eBay authenticity guarantee
you'll never get faked over again the
service currently covers eligible items
across sneakers watches handbags jewelry
and streetwear we feel more confident in
ordering online knowing that an expert
at eBay is authenticating our purchases
any purchase backed by the authenticity
guarantee is sent to the authentic
authentication team who personally
inspect the item check it against the
listing and authenticate it it's a world
full of fakes it's time to get real with
eBay authenticity guarantee I feel like
if eBay authenticity guarantee was a
real housewife that would be their
tagline totally in a world full of fakes
it's time to get real with eBay
authenticity guarantee honestly a
housewife should take that 100 ensure
your next purchase is the real deal with
eBay authenticity guarantee cause you
want to know why ask me why why
everybody deserves real visit ebay.com
for the terms today's episode is also
brought to you by seed all right if
you've been wanting to get on like a
Prebiotic probiotic Journey are you
concerned with your gut health well
check out seeds ds01 daily symbiotic it
is a plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic
with 24 strain that have been clinically
or scientifically studied for its
benefits so it's free from 14 classes of
allergens which are defined by the efsa
including sugar-free vegan soy-free
Sesame free gluten-free peanut free ampa
free dairy free shellfish free corn free
I think a lot of people want to get into
probiotics and prebiotics but they're
limited with their dietary restrictions
but C's got all the bases covered it has
no binders no preservatives you take two
capsules once a day on an empty stomach
and it's engineered to survive so some
people also have to take in probiotics
and probiotics and not had success with
them and that's most likely because once
you take them they actually don't
survive the journey down your digestive
track but the seed probiotic is
engineered to survive your internal and
external vitamins so their capsule and
capsule via cap safeguards viability
through digestion for delivery of an
average of 100 of their probiotic
starting dose to your colon the outer
capsule also serves as an elegant
barrier to oxygen moisture and Heat so
you might ask what are the benefits of a
probiotic Prebiotic a huge one is
digestive health you know do delicious
it promotes it promotes Digestive Health
it reinforces healthy stool hydration
and ease of evacuation and it supports
gut ease from occasional
gastrointestinal discomfort there's also
a lot of skin benefits they have four
specific probiotic strains that have
been shown to promote healthy skin and
reinforce a healthy gut skin access
so start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com toast and use code toast to
redeem thirty percent off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's
seedseed.com toast and use code toast
thank you Claudia welcome our fifth and
final story Gigi Hadid already yeah time
flies when you're with your swirlies
four
and Kendall five no no no no you're
right well that's good because I had to
ask so many stories to add the Skins one
okay yeah that was going to be moved to
Tomato something felt wrong sorry with
the double dipping yeah no we're not
gonna lie Lizzy low hang up until
tomorrow we'll talk about it tomorrow
but I'm really happy for her I mean I
guess we could talk about it no no by
the way it really is it some stories
like are obviously so major like
somebody died or somebody gave birth and
it's like oh congrats or that's so sad
and it's hard to make a podcast out of
that you know yeah yeah but you just
still want to mention it like all right
so I guess this is us mentioning it
Lindsay gave birth I'm really happy for
her okay so is that the fourth story no
okay so we're doing six yeah
but this is four I think whatever this
story is crazy Gigi Hadid has been
released after being arrested for
marijuana in the Cayman Islands so Gigi
had a bumpy start to her summer vacation
the model was embarking on a girl's trip
to the Cayman Islands on July 10th on
Claudia's birthday when she was arrested
at Owen Robertson Gigi's been locked up
since my birthday no I think it's just
coming out E news has learned according
to the local Outlet Cayman Morrow Road
shortly after Gigi and her pal arrived
via private plane custom officials
allegedly found quote ganja and utensils
used for the consumption of ganja in
their luggage Hadid and her friend were
then arrested on quote suspicion
importation of ganja and importation of
utensils we're calling it ganja I guess
that's what they call it there that's
crazy I thought like that's like what
teenagers call it got some ganj you know
the uh importation of utensils used for
the consumption of ganja the outlet
reports adding that they were taken to
the prisoner Detention Center where they
were released on bail two days later she
and her friend were formally charged
during a court appearance where they
pleaded guiltium or both find a thousand
dollars according to the local newspaper
they're not facing any charges her rep
told E news that jihi was traveling with
marijuana purchased legally in New York
City with a medical license it has also
been legal for medical use in Grand
Cayman since 2017. her record remains
clear and she enjoyed the rest of her
time on the island okay I mean like
obviously pot is not a big deal
especially in America like it's legal
legal in a lot of places but like I feel
like a lot of people do this
when I was reading Andy Cohen's book
like his first Diary is like a million
years ago I thought it was so crazy and
then like Brittany Greiner like
pot is so normalized but like the amount
of people who travel with it out of the
country is so dangerous like you really
shouldn't and obviously like pot is pot
it's like not a big deal it's like
traveling with like you know
a beer or whatever you can't travel with
a beer but you know what I'm saying
um I feel like this is an important
reminder like just because it's so
embedded in our culture like doesn't
mean in other countries like it's not a
serious offense and I watch Locked Up
Abroad and you can really through kind
of you know circumstances out of your
own control end up in a Nicaraguan
prison and it's really crazy and I guess
this is also important to note that like
even if in the country medical use is
legal maybe you're transporting maybe
you're like even locked up until they
can prove that yours was of medical use
no and it's like even if it's legal
there and legal here to take it from one
state to record it right I feel like
this is just an important reminder
because pot is like so embedded smuggle
it right put up your presence like
because no don't no I'm kidding I'm
kidding no I'm saying like it's like
smuggling it's like smuggling like
because pot is so embedded in our
culture I think people like totally
forget oh I have a vape pen and they
throw it in like it's really not smart I
feel like we all learned it with like
Brittany Greiner and this is another
example like do not travel out of the
country with pot I think Interstate
drugs with drugs of course but I don't
think people are like you know actually
maybe people are bringing like blocks of
cocaine I don't know but people who
aren't like drug smugglers are just like
throwing you know a joint in their
makeup case and hoping nobody finds it
but like it's so dangerous and it is
illegal and it's like one of those
things like just because like you know
even places where it's not legal in
America like I feel like you know cops
like look past it they don't do that at
the border you know yeah you've got to
be smart this is an important reminder
it is illegal yeah crazy story crazy
story
um you think we're gonna get a GG mug
shot
I don't know how it works in in celebs
no and also in like celeb world like no
but celebs we always see their emotions
no but like say in America sometimes
they get arrested like and we don't see
a mug shot you know
as soon as you get booked but like you
know what I mean yeah but did they get a
mug shot I feel like when there's a mug
shot we see it of course of course no
but sometimes there's not a mug shot
yeah well that's just I saw the funniest
meme it was like me getting arrested
taking my mug shots and then they like
take it oh send me that yeah no totally
hilarious I love memes
Jackie loves memes like nobody sends and
receives more memes than jaggy I send
memes all day long you're kind of like
keeping meme culture alive
single-handedly I send memes to like I
have a roster of people who I send memes
to and everyone gets a different meme
like I said Ben a lot of memes so I'm
like that makes sense so Ben yeah I send
Olivia a you motherhood
did should I send her a lot of memes I
don't think I don't know she's kind of
like too young like young kids don't
[__] with memes yeah I have to look at
our DMs I send you so many memes I love
it because any memes that I find like
genuinely funny I know you're gonna find
funny too but like meme culture is
definitely kind of a like chewy
Millennial thing and it's waning for
sure but the memes I get served fire
flame fire yeah you should share more
memes to your story I should you guys
don't know how I love memes she Chuckles
they're so good and there's some classic
setups that I love like classic um
images
just such good stuff Jackie's kind of
like a number one consumer of meme
culture and that's a fun fact about me
though yeah you might not know yeah
now are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am is this the life-saving
news I've been asking you to talk about
it is the fan claims Kim Kardashian
skims bodysuit saved her life after
being shot four times
so Angela Wiley went viral on Tick Tock
after revealing his tragic story turned
endorsement for skims oh I was my my
whole thing on this was like I've been
hearing this girl telling the story
about oskim's bodysuit saved her life
and I'm like if Kim doesn't put this
[__] in some sort of billboard oh I
mean I don't know if she's put her in a
billboard but it's an endorsement in the
sense not of the paid investment just
have a the real meaning of the word
right got it a recommendation for the
brand
um because she said that she was shot
four times on January 1st 2023 while she
was waiting for a lift and she said her
injuries would have been worse if she
wasn't wearing a bodysuit from skims she
said Kim Kardashian saved my life this
New Year's I got shot four times the
night I got shot under my dress I was
wearing a skim shaping bodysuit it was
so tight on me that literally it kept me
from bleeding out she said call it fate
or Jesus but I'm gonna call it Kim no
but for real thanks Kim okay first of
all like because she just glazed over
like I was shot four times right what is
everything okay like what happened did
they get the guy right
um now that we move past that initial
shock this actually makes a lot of sense
like if you've seen the skim's body
suits like when you pick them up they're
literally the size of like Harry's
t-shirt like they're tiny and of course
they're built to stretch and whatever
but they're really meant to hold you in
and you know when you think holding in
I'm thinking you know cellulite I'm
thinking fupa I'm thinking saggy skin
I'm not thinking blood intestines but
the math makes sense the science is is
sciencing yeah it's like a little
tourniquet for the road no it's
literally a tourniquet I I Kim
absolutely has to respond I'm sure she's
seen the story it's everywhere and they
need to do like a really sickening photo
shoot like
I need to figure out like the slogan and
that's not like insensitive towards like
gun violence you know it's not gonna be
like a gun themed photo shoot yeah but
like it should be like a glamorous
snatch but the slogan has to be like
I don't want it to be insensitive
because like this girl was shot but it
sounds like she's like you know moved
like she's kind of you know healed
physically but also mentally because
she's like making jokes about it
um so I think she'd be down to like
maybe get creative yeah we need a slogan
that like
I don't know like it's it's dicey yeah
yeah though the Sims marketing team has
some really great brains on it yeah but
I feel like it's like two skims it could
save your life
I got it I got it I got it I got it I
just want to be like a little harsh
skims no
I'm [__] this up
choose skims your life might depend on
it yeah that's like a little extreme but
like honestly it's pushing the
boundaries of creative advertising um
choose skins as if your life depends on
it
because it does because it might because
it might
something needs to be done now I'm not
saying they should do like a
blood-themed photo shoot no I think they
should give her like the Hollywood
treatment
I have to imagine skims has already
reached out like skims is so in tune
with like social media put her in a
campaign but I think they'll send her a
[__] ton of scams and she'll be posting
about it I don't know
I think they actually might they're
always putting like random people in
that's true they they love like and they
don't do like one campaign a year they
do like one a month right okay maybe
they would like put her in a campaign
but not do a campaign around like
bulletproof skins yeah also I don't
think they can like legally say
like this might have been a coincidence
but like maybe also the bullets were
just like literally in the perfect place
for someone to not bleed out it's like
they probably can't legally you know
it's false advertising like it'll save
your life because it might not you might
get shot and wearing a skims body suit
and still die you could get shot in the
head it's also very true
so there's a way to work with her there
is but I just don't know if they're
gonna go down I think they'll Embrace
her into the skims family it's dicey the
skim Squad yeah no that's good American
Squad yeah what is a skim crew called
like there is it should be called The
Skin squirrelies yeah but there's not a
an evergreen crew no
okay sorry of the moment so those were
the fast five stories that was felt like
11 stories but like all of them
noteworthy and I guess it was like
technically eight if you count Lindsay
Lohan and the divorce is being two yeah
well you know what there was a lot going
on today yeah it had to be done it's
hard to count sometimes that's the thing
this isn't the morning math you know no
otherwise young Sheldon would be hosting
it what are your thoughts on young
Sheldon thus far I love him what are you
up to uh season two me too I'm watching
alongside with you he met the other
Prodigy which I was obsessed with I want
more of that Dynamic Paige is she's not
always on the show but she's in episodes
up until the current season she kind of
goes down a dark path at one point like
it's kind of it's like she's like she's
kind of crazy and I loved when the
parents got together and the dad George
senior was like getting a dress for them
like talking about their marital issues
that The Prodigy has caused the more you
watch the more you see the best
character on the show is George senior
yeah he's really great yeah
um I yeah I I really like it I'm so
curious to see like how Sheldon takes a
turn because you were saying you know
I'm watching alongside even like even in
season two he becomes like really
annoying and self-righteous like he's
obviously the smartest kid in every room
that he's in and as a kid you don't
realize like the power that it gives you
but he becomes like a preteen and a teen
and he becomes like a [__] pain in
the ass and he becomes rude yeah and
it's not cute when you're not a kid and
you're like not exactly like did you get
to the episode where the there's a girl
in the town who's in a car accident yeah
and it really shakes the whole
neighborhood that's what I watch and
then immediately after they get the call
he said can you take me to Radio Shack
so right and it's so rude but like he's
still the kids so you're like okay
whatever but that sort of energy that's
the exact energy he has when he grows up
and he's not cute anymore yeah and
you're older like you should know better
when you're a kid like you're not in
tune with social social cues just like
me apparently right right
so glad you're enjoying it I knew you
would it's a camper tested counselor
approved yeah it's so camper so today
was kind of a fabulous episode a lot
going on thanks for making it to the end
if you uh haven't yet head over to
sportsociety.com pickles
c-l-a-u-s-s-e-n pickles
um our collab pickle wine is here and
it's really good you know you'll have to
see my taste test when are you posting
it whenever I feel like it today yeah we
live like a lot of like pre-scheduled
content like we had like a bunch of
photo shoots like I don't want to mess
with like the flow of like the actual
professionals yeah just another day you
drop so I'll send it to photo shoot I'll
send my content to the social team I did
the same photo shoot that you dropped
yesterday no
oh that's a patreon joke so check out
our patreon that we just dropped at
patreon.com the toast and while you're
surfing the web head over to the camper
in the counselor.com and pre-order your
copy of the camber and counselor signed
copies are still available at Talk Shop
live you know what I'm doing right now
surfing the web exactly and where are
you going thecamber and the
counselor.com and then patreon.com the
toast and then Sports society.com
pickles wow today was like a very heavy
like self promo day but you know what
like you see these lights they don't
stay on by themselves no and the lights
are on right they're shining right I'm
starving okay let's see it's lunch
love you thank you so much for listening
to The Chosen Illinois Morning Show we
deliver the past five stories you need
to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up also
available podcast
books all the places
talented we are the sign off hits
different in studio like I'll say that I
feel that and so does the love yeah bye